I want to extend my warmest condolences  to the family and many friends of Elijah  Cummings who are celebrating his life  today in Baltimore  not long ago I met with Elijah in the  Oval Office and I saw the passion he had  with me for lowering prescription drug  prices he had a very strong passion for  that we're going to get it done I will  tell you we are absolutely getting it  done but I was with Elijah and I have  rarely seen anybody want to do something  like that and we're going to have that  and prescription prices are coming down  we had the first year in over 50 years  where they have actually come down and  if we could get support on the other  side we'll get those prices so far lower  than they are right now you wouldn't  even believe it I think people are gonna  be very surprised so I want to give my  warmest respects please